These are the top Fable 5 use cases you must try before we lose this model to API pricing in just a few days.
Now use case number one is clone and customize any software you want.
I did a full demo of this on my YouTube using whisper flow. We used deep research to figure out how
whisper flow is working under the hood and then we use Fable 5 to recreate it locally.
So it not only mimicked exactly what whisper flow does, but it did it completely on our
machine. So it was free. It was secure and we could customize it anyway we want.
Now use case number two is a usage audit of your cloud code. What am I talking about?
I'm saying open up cloud code and have Fable look at your past 20, 30, 40, 50 sessions inside of
cloud code and figure out what you're doing right, what you're doing wrong, what sort of skills
it can create and what can turn into automations. Now use case number three is building an
agentic OS. Now your agentic OS doesn't have to look like this crazy thing like mine with a full
on voice mode, but you do need to build a foundation. And that foundation should look something
like this. It's kind of tied to use case number two. It's taking all of your daily in your weekly
tasks, turning those into skills in those skills, if it makes sense, into automations. You should
do this with everything that you use cloud code for. So for me, that's research content. My
sales, my agency, this is the backbone of a true agentic OS. Now use case number four is doing a
code review. This is one of the best use cases for Fable 5. If you have a complicated project that
you've been working on for a while, now is the time to get a second pair of eyes with the most
powerful model in the world and have it tell you what's working and what isn't. And lastly,
and probably the most obvious use case is using Fable 5 to start complex projects that are beyond
the scope of something like opus. For example, take a look at this game that was created using Fable 5.
This is running completely on the browser. You hit it looks like some triple A video game demo.
And what was it created with? Purely with Fable 5. This is just a small taste of the
kinds of projects you can create now that just weren't possible before. Now if you want to
deeper dive on all these use cases, definitely check out my YouTube for more.